everyone has a choice including you
mouth so what's this all about you
having no choice in descendants 3 all of
your friends turn into stone for some
strange reason you stay exactly the same
we've always trusted you mal you're like
the best VK ever but the trailers are
painting you in a different light are
you responsible for turning your friends
into stone we're sure you have your
reasons but come on did you really have
to turn dude into stone - he's just a
cute and innocent pup if there's one
thing we know for sure it's that some of
our favorite BK's turn into stone in
descendents 3 and we're dying to know
why a possible explanation for everyone
turning to stone except for mal is that
she's trying to protect them from
something a lot of the villains have a
bone to pick with mal
so what if they tried to trick her we
later see dragon mouse spitting fire at
someone standing on an Oregon rooftop
could this villain have told now that
she needs to fight her alone or else
turning everyone into stone would keep
them safe for the most part and it would
stop them from trying to save or help
mal we just hope that no ill intentions
people will stumble across bin and the
VJs stone sculptures now might be the
one who turns her friends into stone
after all she does know how to use
spells now yells out I had no choice as
a pink smog clears revealing her
petrified friends so it sure looks like
she had something to do with it now
feels like it's her responsibility to
save our Don so maybe working as a team
just aliens in her schedule Celia said
that these friendships will be tests
summer Bend summer break
could she be referring to the fact that
mal is going to turn her friends into
stone now might agree to fight her enemy
one on one but turning her friends to
stone sounds a little brash it's
possible that a villain secretly reached
out to mal asking her to fight
one-on-one
but when mal agrees her friends
instantly turned to stone we know for a
fact that mouths magical force field is
a deep purple with the magic spell we
see in the official trailer is clearly
pink and since there's only one mean
girl who looks pretty in pink or
guessing Audrey might have something to
do with Ben Jay Carlos Evie and dudes
predicaments we know for a fact that
Audrey is getting up to no good in
descendants three she yells out during
Ben and mouse engagement and his later
seemed stealing the Queen's crown and
Maleficent scepter from the Arden Museum
she never likes mal and blames her for
all of her problems
Graeme I don't think you want to be
talking to his girl unless you feel like
taking another hundred-year nap if you
pause the official trailer during Mao's
dragon scene you can see what looks like
Audrey standing on the rooftop now
showers her with dragon fire and the
scene changes to show the BK's and then
being turned to stone
so would have now turned her friends to
stone by mistake she might have made a
deal and lost and now she's paying
dearly for it another explanation for
Ben and the VK is turning to stone has
everything to do with Celia don't let
this little tarot card reader fool you
she's all about making money and
collecting debts I already have during
the trailer we see Celia take Hades
ember and throw it into a well the ember
explodes and mouth shrieks in dismay
clearly the ember was the only thing
powerful enough to reverse the sleep
spell but it looks like Mao has other
things to worry about because soon
enough we see then turn into a beast
we can clearly see the V case in the
background when Celia destroys the Ember
and if you take a look at the scene with
the pink fog you can see the same house
in the backdrop this makes us think that
the embers destruction immediately turns
the V Ches into stone just look at how
their position
carlos is bending down to pet do just as
the ember goes up in smoke
it sure looks like these two scenes are
back-to-back and if that's the case
Celia destroying the ember might be the
reason why the VKS
turned to stone but if there's one thing
we just can't shake it's the fact that
the fog surrounding the PK's and bin is
bright pink and not blue
we mean if the ember was behind the
spell wouldn't smoke be blue so this
brings us back to Audrey or should we
say uma here's a theory Audrey is being
controlled by uma via her seashell
necklace we see Emma's necklace glowing
in the trailer and audrey is also
wearing a high-neck dress which could
easily hide the necklace on top of that
we see audrey casting the sleep spell on
our Don only to later see her fast
asleep in her room so uma could have
possessed Audrey's body cast the spell
and then put her to sleep until she
needed to use her again although many of
us want mal and uma to be friends again
it looks like umas need for revenge is
way too strong in umas trailer she says
uma might be pretending to help Mau to
gain her trust while she secretly
controls Audrey from afar if Audrey can
turn fairy godmother to stone it
shouldn't be too hard for her to set her
sights on Mouse friends it sure looks
like all of the villains are working
together on this one which is probably
why Celia pulled the betrayal card so
which theory makes the most sense to you
sound off in the comments section below
for more videos about your favorite TV
shows and movies subscribe to the things
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up thanks for watching see
you next time
[Music]